ce break site donc qui s'annonce le
risque c'est quoi c'est qu'il ya un
effet domino non parce que ce qu'on a vu
lorsque les gens ont commencé à
comprendre ce que ça veut dire break
site je suis d'accord avec vous une
grande erreur politique et une bêtise en
fait une très grande bêtise les les
sondages montrent que y compris en
france d'ailleurs
les gens croient plus en l'europe parce
qu'ils ont compris ce que vous venez
d'expliquer que plus on sera petit plus
les autres continents vont nous imposer
leur point de vue plus on sera grand et
fort plus les prochaines générations
peuvent prendre leurs décisions
autonomes et ne pas se laisser imposer
par la chine demain par exemple leur
manière de vivre
donc les dents le eurobaromètre les
français à 67% maintenant pense que
l'union européenne est une bonne chose
les allemands à 81% il ya eu 20 % de
points de plus
depuis quelques années lorsque les gens
voient ce qui se passe